cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com you know how long the
American Revolution took oh
um eight years 20 years 20 years started
I believe it was 19 I'm sorry 19 17 64.
was the beginning of what we described
as the revolutionary period and could
you imagine
and then the first battle started in
1775 and then a year and a month later
the founding fathers signed the
Declaration of Independence so so hold
on there a minute
a decade of people being oppressed and
beaten down and nothing and then it's 11
years later
when the when the regular is coming to
Boston and say it's it's simplified 10
events Boston Tea Party there was uh was
it the Tea Act or whatever made it
easier for the East India Trading
Company
yeah the British crown was trying to
basically uh essentially bail out these
India Trading Company to a certain
degree that's how we view it and this
made it more difficult for American tea
producers to trade and they're like
you're bringing in this teeth from
outside here when we're trying to trade
here so they dump it into the ocean the
crown then says you got to pay all that
back they say no we don't and they say
then you are in rebellion and we're
deploying regulars to Boston to get
things under control so then the people
in Boston said outside of the city we're
the law then the regulars were like were
ordered go take their weapons away they
are not the law and these people said
enough and then the first shots were
fired and there was no ordering and yet
nobody knows exactly who uh according
according to the stories they say it's
not sure who fired the first shot but I
believe it was the Americans who fired
on a regular and may have killed one of
them it's interesting because entirely
possible
my point is my point is it a lot of
people are screaming 1776 blah blah I'm
like dude the history of the American
Revolution is not like a bunch of
founding fathers got together smugly and
proudly wrote these brilliant things and
said there must be Independence bang to
gavel delivered to the king and the
Kingwood the King was sending troops to
the to rebellious colonies for a decade
before fighting actually broke out so
what we're looking at right now with the
rise of Public Square One of the most
powerful tools you're making a great
Point here as well because it was an
awful lot of pamphleteering in coffee
houses that sort of raised Consciousness
and that's really what we're doing here
like I said the war isn't over and it's
not that we've lost we just need to know
what we need to do to win it you know we
need to be serious about the scale of
the opposition I mean it literally is
something akin to the British Empire
that we're staring down here you know
it's a giant clothes Globe spanning it's
and it's here is a culture remember that
John Adams defended the British soldiers
in the Boston Massacre because he
believed in due process
and those kinds of those kinds of
natural rights and freedoms
I feel like a significant problem and we
talking you know talking about schools
earlier that's where the the big
disconnect is we've raised multiple
generation generations of children that
do not hold even the the founding
principles they don't even know the
founding principles they don't know why
property rights are important they don't
know what happens when you take property
rights away from a society they don't
know why the rule of law like why
innocent before you know innocent before
proven guilty is important they don't
understand because they haven't been
taught they've been taught almost
exclusively the worst thing that can
happen is someone could say something
racist you might someone might
understand what you say as being bigoted
as if the worst thing that's possible
the worst thing that they can imagine is
hurting someone's feelings and this is a
massive massive problem in our society
yeah I agree with that as well I mean I
think that's why we had what happened in
Canada I think people don't understand
history they don't understand the
implications of you mean they're not
saying Parliament because they said oh
well he fought Russia and we hate Russia
now the everything is measured by a
modern standard and it leaves especially
Young's generation completely lost I
think your Point's completely valid I
think the right does need to decide what
they are objectively building towards if
you don't have a blueprint for a
building it's going to be very difficult
to come up with something and ultimately
I think that's why the right is unable
to organize because they don't share a
common vision and I think
furthermore that's because we think oh
we'll just let everyone be on their own
and they'll make their own decisions and
they'll have their own values and
everything will be fine and we know
that's a failing system but I think Tin
Tin I think you're making a really good
point that I hadn't really thought about
to be honest um that is a great Point
20-year War man and we're in the early
stages with the coffee houses
pamphleteering right now I mean I don't
doubt that the King's Men would have
gone into a coffee house and taken all
the pamphlets and beating all the people
in there spreading around that and we're
those guys who are getting whacked with
the stick now and that's and that's fine
but but fortunately we've got to carry a
Throwbacks we've got to keep
pamphleteering fortunately for those who
are meeting and having conversations uh
to this degree about winning culture War
building culture
we're not actually having the King's Men
come into our homes and take from yes
right but we have a third amendment so
we're still practicing to a certain
degree but what we are dealing with is
censorship and so they are ripping the
papers from us and you know kicking
people out of the out of the out of the
Public Square as it were but uh I'm
grateful that it is not violent conflict
and I and I hope that doesn't come to be
the worrying thing is with things like
January 6 and with the 529 far left
attacks on the White House these things
it's worrisome Aaron Danielson being
shot twice in the in that was his name
right Aaron Danielson you mean with when
Michael Reinhold did it shot him twice
in the chest these are scary things and
so a lot of people I will tell you this
the last thing anyone needs right now is
real conflict what we need right now is
in the truest sense of the founding
fathers yo writing pamphlets yeah and
using pseudonyms and spreading the ideas
and building the sentiment that
eventually led to a shatter of
confidence in the crown and then the
people in this country are like look
we're the funny thing is the Declaration
of Independence the reason we say that's
the birth date of this country despite
the fact that it was actually you could
argue the Treaty of Paris which was I
think was 1883 was that what it was 1883
the Treaty of Pierce yeah I don't
remember uh was it Treaty of Paris when
we were basically like
okay that's fine the crown will stop
fighting to the American people the
moment we said we were independent we
weren't to the crown uh-uh it wasn't
until yeah I mean George said they would
never accept it September 3rd 1783 yeah
17. and that was the official end of the
American war for independence where the
British crown finally recognized okay
you're independent but to us we are
independent for six years before that
sure but that's but I I think you're
totally right like the modern version of
pantheering is obviously these podcasts
right yeah so you know we are all doing
great work but I think we can't be
allowed to fall into complacency and
think oh wow we need to need to do much
else right because like the scope of the
problem is well and this is the issue
that same people are like we're not
winning we're not winning they say it
over and over and over again Donald
Trump said that uh you know the election
was stolen it was stolen and then people
didn't show up to vote in Georgia and
what should have been easily won a
senate seat for a republican went to a
Democrat somehow with all the polling
and and there were interviews done where
guys outside were like what's the point
they stole it anyway and Brianna Wu said
she ran Trump's statements at as
advertisements in Georgia I think said
in Georgia or she used the statements
advertisements I don't know if it was in
Georgia because Trump was suppressing
the vote by telling people you are
losing my point is we have gained
strategic grounds we have tremendous
victories in the culture war and now we
need to like when when the when the when
the enemy is breaking ranks you don't
say all right that's it everybody time
to pack and you say you say charge yeah
so now uh Public Square is one of the
most powerful tools and look I'm not
I've never even heard of this what is
this Public Square is an app where in
order to have it's a list of businesses
and in order to be on it you have to
agree to American values if you say I
support Free Speech the Constitution
families things like this and uh so
Casper coffee is on Public Square we're
huge fans they're sponsoring our Miami
event they um I think they did they did
a SPAC deal so they went public they're
tremendously successful and they're
basically creating an anti-amazon
they're going to you you download the
app it's pretty cool oh it's amazing
everyone download Public Square you
download the app you sign up you search
for businesses in your area
America I believe so far but they're
launching in Canada pretty soon so check
it out well because What's it gonna be
is going to be like traditional British
values in the UK I think so but I mean
we can literally the the standard would
be do you agree with the values on the
Magna Carta that's literally literally
where I mean this this whole thing with
Russell Brand is actually a violation of
the Magna Carta like this is literally a
textbook violation check this out okay
you pull up the map and it will show you
all the businesses in your area that
support your values that sounds great
and so this this maximizes by cut
potential so for us in in you know West
Virginia I know a lot of businesses
support of ours they haven't heard of
Public Square we got to get them to
figure it out because we can pull up
restaurants and we know that by them
being on Public Square for one they're
probably fans so we know we're gonna be
welcome there and we know that our money
is going to go to someone who's helping
their children who believes in this
country and we keep the money in our
parallel economy and we start to strip
the resources from the what Corporation
with the Miami event we're going to be
giving out a bunch of this is the plan
okay I'm not organizing the event so my
understanding is the people my team
who's who's working on it have uh set up
swag bags full of samples from all the
companies that are on Public Square I
I'm so excited that's great yeah and
they're and they're an official sponsor
so uh we're gonna have the CEO Michael
Seifert he's going to be uh coming on
IRL uh I think the day before and then
he's gonna be on stage with Hannah
Claire and Josie the redhead libertarian
talking about all this stuff yeah is it
gonna be super oh Michael yeah nice yeah
it's gonna be super excited they're they
they they are on the flagship in the
culture world as far as I'm concerned
and an anti-amazon and their success is
just this example I'm talking about
organizational capacity that's such a
good thing is though you know the left
is going to see this right yes of course
they're gonna be like uh we don't think
so what can they do well they can take
you out there all it is is an app that
sells jerky and t-shirts pancake mix
they they don't need a reason I agree
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time